الى الولايات المتحده حيث نقلت وكاله
السوشيات عن مصادر متطلعه قولها ان الرئيس
الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب يواجه تهمه
جنائيه واحده على الاقل في لائحه الاتهام
التي اقرتها هيئه محلفين في من هاته
واوضحت الوكاله ان الرئيس السابق يواجه
تهما متعدده اخرى بتزوير سجلات تجاريه
سيكشف عنها عندما يسلم نفسه يوم الثلاثاء
المقبل واضافت ان ترامب سيتعرض للاحتجاز
على الاغلب كما يحدث لاي شخص يواجه تهما
وستؤخذ بصماته لكن لن يتم تقييده كما رجحت
ان يتم اطلاقه سراحه في اليوم نفسه
في غضون ذلك نقلت وكاله بدون مصدر المطلع
قوله الى فريق ترامب القانوني يدرس طلب
نقل قضيه الرئيس السابقه الجنائيه الى
ستاتين ايلاند في مدينه نيويورك وبحسب
المصدر فان هذه الخطوه تاتي بسبب مخاوف
الفريق بان ترامب لن يحصل على محاكمه
عادله في منهات